Speaker 1: I have absolutely huge breaking
news for you.
One of the biggest stories out there.
New details have emerged about Hunter Biden's
laptop e-mails.
Just kidding, I'm not an idiot, but over the
Memorial Day holiday, Fox News really did
pretend to break this explosive story about
a conspiracy theory related to the president's
son, who has nothing to do with his administration
whatsoever.
Check this out.
It was maybe not surprisingly, on Fox and
Friends.
Here we go.
Speaker 6: New details emerging in the Hunter
Biden scandal,
Speaker 4: email reportedly show a meeting
between his then vice president, Father Joe
Biden, and Hunter's business partners from
around the world.
Yes, so we must have had a lot of translators
there in two separate dinners that are chronicled
his laptop as it becomes leaked out more and
more.
Ted Pirro joins us live as the plot thickens
and his dad's presence as vice president very
present.
Speaker 1: Can you believe that, guys?
Now, if you were paying attention all along,
you'd know that they already did this supposed
exclusive in October of twenty twenty.
It's now seven or eight months old.
When Fox reported about, quote, Hunter's ex
partner recounts meeting Joe Biden claims
family paranoid about hiding former VP involvement.
It was a nonstory outside of the Fox Newsmax
conspiracy universe because there was no actual
evidence of anything untoward happening.
It's sort of not shocking that if it's true
that Joe Biden met people that his son worked
with, that that would that would be something
that takes place.
And this is what they cheered on about Trump.
Trump made deals and his kids are involved.
And everybody's so good at business and Trump
helps his kids.
But isn't everybody so great at everything?
But now, if indeed it happened with Joe Biden,
then it's definitely bad.
It's definitely very, very bad.
Let's look at a little bit more of this from
the Fox and Friends report.
Speaker 4: And there's two separate meetings
there.
Thanks, Todd.
Speaker 6: How does he explain the email of
one of the guys at that dinner thanking him,
an executive from Verismo, thanking Hunter
Biden for introducing him to his dad?
We get
Speaker 4: details.
It's in The New York Post today.
Miranda Devine has got a book that's coming
out in September.
It's called Laptop from Hell.
What's really curious?
Speaker 1: OK, now, did you see what Steve
Doocy did there?
This is a really important propaganda technique
to understand, you know, how sometimes Fox
News will insert opinion into news shows by
reporting on what Tucker said the night before.
And then they react to what Tucker said during
the Opinion Show, as if it's news that Tucker
said it.
That's one technique Fox uses to blur the
lines between opinion and news reporting.
The New York Post has now run multiple discredited
stories on the Biden laptop.
And The New York Post is owned by News Corp.,
which also owns Fox News.
So remember this?
The first Hunter Biden story back in October
was published despite Fox News saying we're
not going to touch it.
And even some reporters at The New York Post
saying we really shouldn't publish this crap.
It was widely reported on, including by The
New York Times as we're putting up on the
screen for you.
And at the time, Fox did the same.
They reported on the New York Post story in
order to be able to talk about it without
running the report themselves, which they
said, we can't run this.
This is trash.
Fox decided, let's just run the fact that
The New York Post reported on it and then
that allowed them to do a week of coverage
here.
It's basically the same thing.
Steve Doocy holding up the newspaper from
The New York Post with the story.
So, of course, with this new article, we'll
see whether the claims are even true.
But remember that the track record from the
post on these stories is highlighted by a
Salon article from October.
Fox News rejected Hunter Biden expose a New
York Post writer, refused to put his name
on it.
But then Fox News did weeks of coverage based
on the very New York Post reporting that Fox
News said, we can't actually run this.
This is no good.
This is how they do it.
This is a technique you have to understand.
And it's important that as a savvy media consumer
that we should all aspire to be.
We not only identify the difference between
this is a news report and this is opinion.
And of course, they deliberately blur that
to make it difficult.
But we also are able to distinguish this is
a news report based on a confirmed news report
or this is a news report based on something
that is essentially gossip.
And that's an important distinction to be
able to make as well.
So we'll have more on this on our Instagram,
make sure you're following us on Instagram
The David Pakman Show.
And while you're at it, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman new backyard garden tour.
Some people get mad.
Someone wrote to me saying, David, how dare
you show us those disgusting stink weeds in
your backyard.
Most people liked it, though, so there will
be a new garden tour on my Instagram David
Pakman